Ce à quoi je pense tout le temps
c'est au thème de cette session, qui s'appelle simplicité.
Et j'appellerais presque ça être simple d'esprit,
mais au le meilleur sens du terme.
J'essaie de comprendre deux choses très simples :
comment vivre et comment mourir, point.
C'est tout ce que j'essaie de faire, toute la journée.
J'essaie aussi de prendre quelques repas et de grignoter
et, vous savez, gronder mes enfants et faire toutes les choses normales
qui vous aident à garder les pieds sur terre.
Alors, j'ai eu la chance de naître rêveuse.
Ma soeur ainée était occupée à torturer mes parents,
et ils étaient occupés à la torturer.
J'ai eu la chance d'être complètement ignorée --
chose fabuleuse réellement, je dois vous le dire.
Alors j'ai eu la liberté de traverser ma vie en rêvassant
Et j'ai finalement rêvé mon chemin jusqu'à la NYU à un très bon mement -- en 1967,
où j'ai rencontré un homme qui essayait de faire sauter la fac de maths de la NYU
Et je lui écrivais des poèmes atroces et je lui tricotais des pulls.
Et les féministes nous détestaient, et le tableau entier était faussé
du début jusqu'à la fin.
Mais je continuais à écrire de la mauvaise poésie, et lui n'a pas fait sauter le bâtiment de maths,
mais il est parti à Cuba.
Mais je lui ai donné l'argent, parce que je venais de Riverdale
donc j'avais plus d'argent que lui.
(rires)
Et,vous connaissez la rangaine, c'était une bonne chose d'aider la cause.
Mais ensuite il est revenu, et des choses se sont passées,
et j'ai décidé que je détestais vraiment ce que j'écrivais,
je trouvais ça terrible, de la prose à l'eau de rose terrible.
Et j'ai décidé que je voulais raconter,
mais je voulais quand même raconter une histoire narrative
et j'avais encore envie de raconter mes histoires.
Alors j'ai décidé de commencer à dessiner. Ca ne pouvait pas être si difficile.
Et donc voilà que je suis devenue
illustratrice éditoriale grâce à, vous savez,
un pur hasard, une pure ignorance.
Et on a lancé un studio --
en fait, c'est Tibor qui à commencé un studio, appelé M & Company.
Et la devise de M & Company était : " nous ne savons rien
mais ce n'est pas grave, on va le faire tout de même. "
D'ailleurs, c'est mieux de ne rien savoir,
parce que si on en sait trop, on ne progresse pas.
Alors, la devise était :
" sans limites et sans peurs ".
Et -- mon boulot, j'ai décroché le meilleur boulot sur terre,
était de rêvasser, et en fait de trouver des idées absurdes
et heureusement il y avait assez de personnes --
et c'était une équipe et un travail collectif,
ce n'était pas moi toute seule qui trouvait des idées absurdes.
Mais le fait est que j'étais là en tant que moi-même, une rêveuse.
Et quelques-unes des choses -- je veux dire, M & Company c'est toute une histoire,
et on avait aussi besoin de gagner de l'argent,
alors on a décidé de créer une série de produits.
Et ces montres là,
essayer de faire des produits beaux et pleins d'esprit --
peut-être pas essayer, avec un peu de chance réussir --
parce que pouvoir parler du contenu,
casser les attentes, et utiliser l'humour et la surprise,
l'élégance et l'humanité dans notre travail c'était vraiment important pour nous.
C'était un moment assez impersonnel dans le monde du design
et on voulait montrer que le contenu est ce qui est important,
pas le paquet, pas l'emballage.
On doit être des journalistes, on doit être des inventeurs,
on doit utiliser son imagination plus que tout.
Alors, la bonne nouvelle est que j'ai un chien
et même si je ne suis pas sûre de croire en la chance --
je ne sais pas en quoi je crois, c'est une question très compliquée --
mais je sais qu'avant de partir, je tire sa queue sept fois.
Alors dès qu'il voit une valise dans la maison,
parce que, vous savez, tout le monde est toujours en train de partir,
ils tirent toujours la queue de ce chien génial,
et il se réfugie dans l'autre pièce.
Mais je suis capable de faire la transition entre travailler pour des enfants et
travailler pour les adultes et travailler pour les enfants et vice-versa,
parce que, vous savez, je peux dire que je suis immature,
et d'une certaine façon c'est vrai.
Je pourrais dire que je n'ai pas compris --
je n'en suis pas fière, mais je n'ai pas compris
disons 95 pourcent des présentations qui ont été faites à cette conférence.
Mais j'ai pris plein de notes et fait plein de beaux dessins
et j'ai un magnifique oignon du discours de Murray Gell-Mann.
J'ai aussi une belle page de gribouillages du discours de Jonathan Woodham.
Alors, il ressort des bonnes choses de l'incompréhension, vous savez --
(Rires)
-- j'en ferai un tableau et il fera plus tard partie de mon travail.
Alors je suis ouverte aux possibilités de ne pas savoir
et de découvrir quelque chose de nouveau.
Alors, dans l'écriture pour enfant, ça semble simple et ça l'est.
On doit faire tenir une histoire en 32 pages généralement.
Et ce qu'on doit faire c'est la réduire à ce qu'on veut vraiment dire,
en espérant que vous ne parlez pas aux enfants avec condescendance
et que vous ne parlez pas d'une manière qui
vous savez, serait insupportable à lire plus d'une fois.
Alors, j'espère que j'écris vous savez,
des livres qui sont bons pour les enfants et les adultes.
Mais ce qui se reflète dans la peinture,
je ne pense pas que ce soit différent pour les enfants et pour les adultes.
J'essaie d'utilier la même imagination, la même fantaisie,
le même amour du langage.
Alors, vous savez, j'ai beaucoup d'amis qui sont merveilleux à regarder.
Ça c'est Andrew Gatz, il est entré par la porte et je lui ai dit
"Assieds-toi là", et j'ai pris plein de photos.
Et le fauteuil Bertoia dans l'arrière plan est mon fauteuil préféré.
Alors j'arrive à y mettre toutes les choses que j'aime,
en espérant qu'un dialogue entre adultes et enfants s'instaurera à différents niveaux,
et, je l'espère, différentes sortes d'humours évolueront.
Et les livres sont réellement les journaux de ma vie.
Je n'ai jamais -- je n'aime pas les intrigues.
Je ne sais pas ce qu'une intrigue veut dire.
Je ne supporte pas l'idée de quoi que ce soit qui commence au début,
vous savez, début, milieu et fin, ça me terrifie vraiment,
parce que ma vie est trop imprévue et confuse,
et c'est comme ça que je l'aime.
Mais bref, donc j'étais, nous étions à Venise,
et c'est notre chambre, et j'ai fait ce rêve
que je portais cette superbe robe verte,
et je regardais par la fenêtre,
et c'était vraiment beau.
Et donc j'ai pu mettre ça dans cette histoire, qui est un alphabet,
et je l'espère passer à autre chose.
La lettre C contient d'autres choses.
J'ai eu la chance aussi de rencontrer l'homme qui est assis sur le lit,
même si là je lui ai fait des cheveux et il n'en a pas --
bon, il en a un peu, bon, il en a eu.
Et avec lui j'ai pu faire un projet vraiment fantastique.
Je travaille pour le New Yorker, et je fais des couvertures, et le 11 septembre est arrivé
et c'était, vous savez, la fin complète et totale du monde tel que nous le connaissions.
Et Rick et moi allions à une soirée dans le Bronx,
et quelqu'un a dit Bronxistan,
et quelqu'un a dit Fareerristan,
et l'idée nous est venue pour la couverture du New Yorker,
que nous avons pu -- nous ne savions pas ce que nous faisions,
on n'essayait pas d'être drôles, on n'essayait pas --
bon, en fait on essayait d'être drôles, ce n'est pas vrai.
On espérait qu'on serait drôles, mais on ne savait pas que ce serait une couverture,
et on ne savait pas que cette image, au moment où c'est arrivé,
serait quelque chose de merveilleux pour beaucoup de gens.
Et c'est vraiment devenu -- je ne sais pas, vous savez,
c'était un de ces moments où les gens ont commencé à rire de ce qui se passait.
Et de, vous savez, des Fattushis, au Taxistan,
pour les Fashtoonks, Botoxia, Pashmina, Khlintunesia, vous savez,
on a pu prendre toute la ville
et rire de cette dimension étrangère, qui sont -- qu'est ce qui se passe ici ?
Qui sont ces gens ? Quelles sont ces tribus ?
Et David Remnick, qui était vraiment merveilleux avec ça,
avait un problème : il n'aimait pas Al Zheimer, Al Zheimers,
parce qu'il pensait que ça insulterait les gens avec Alzheimer.
Mais vous savez, on disait, "David, qui va le savoir ?"
Personne.
(rires)
Donc c'est resté, et c'était, et, vous savez, c'était bien.
Vous savez, dans le cours de ma vie, je ne sais jamais ce qui va arriver
et c'est un peu la part de la beauté.
Et nous étions à Cape Cod, un endroit évidemment plein d'inspiration,
et j'ai pris ce livre, "Les éléments du style" dans une brocante,
et je n'avais -- et je ne l'avais jamais lu à l'école,
parce que j'étais trop occupée à écrire des poèmes et à sécher
etc, à passer mon temps dans les cafés.
Mais je l'ai pris et j'ai commencé à le lire et j'ai pensé, ce livre est incroyable.
J'ai dit qui -- les gens devraient découvrir ce livre.
(rires)
Alors j'ai décidé qu'il avait besoin d'un peu -- qu'il avait besoin d'un lifting, il avait besoin de quelques illustrations.
Et en fait, j'ai appelé, vous savez, j'ai convaincu les héritiers White,
et quelle rencontre de similarités, vous savez,
des juifs polonais, grande famille WASP, et me voilà disant,
j'aimerais faire quelque chose avec ce livre.
Et ils ont dit oui, et ils m'ont laissé complètement libre,
ce qui était une chose géniale, magnifique.
Et j'ai pris les exemples qu'ils m'avaient donné,
et j'ai fait 56 tableaux, en fait.
Alors, ça c'est, je ne sais pas si vous pouvez lire ça.
"Bon, Susan, tu es dans un sacré pétrin.'
Et quand vous avez affaire à la grammaire,
qui est, vous savez, incroyablement sèche,
E.B. White a écrit des choses merveilleuses, poétiques -- et en fait, Strunk --
et ensuite vous arrivez aux règle et, vous savez,
il y a des tas de trucs en grammaire -- " Vous permettez que je pose une question ?
Vous permettez que je vous pose une question ?"
"Feriez, devriez, pourriez ou feriez, devriez, pourriez."
Et "feriez" est le préféré de Coco Chanel, "devriez" est Edith Sitwell,
et "pourriez" est un sujet d'August Sander.
Et, "Il remarqua une grosse tâche au milieu du tapis."
(rires)
Alors il y une espèce de sous-entendu britannique, un thème de roman policier
que j'aime vraiment beaucoup.
Et puis, "Soyez obscure clairement ! Lâchez vous d'une manière compréhensible."
E.B. White nous a donné beaucoup de règles,
qui peuvent soit vous paralyser et vous faire le détester
pour toujours, ou vous pouvez les ignorer, ce que je fais,
ou vous pouvez, je ne sais pas, vous savez, manger un sandwich.
Alors ce que j'ai fait pendant que je peignais, j'ai commencé à chanter,
parce que j'adore vraiment chanter,
et je pense que la musique est la forme d'art la plus élevée.
Donc j'ai commissionné un merveilleux compositeur, Nico Muhly,
qui a écrit 9 chansons, en utilisant le texte,
et nous l'avons interprété à cette fantastique soirée à --
il a écrit de la musique pour les amateurs et pour les professionnels.
Je jouais avec une tasse à thé et un Slinky
dans la principale salle de lecture de la bibliothèque de New York,
où vous êtes supposés être très, très silencieux,
et c'était un évènement phénoménalement merveilleux
et j'espère que nous le referons.
Qui sait ? Le New York Times Select, la page d'éditorial,
m'a demandé de faire une chronique, et ils ont dit que je pouvais faire ce que je voulais.
Donc, une fois par mois pendant l'année dernière
j'ai fait une chronique intitulée Les principes de l'incertitude,
qui, vous savez, je ne sais pas qui est Heisenberg,
mais je sais que je peux utiliser ça, vous savez,
c'est les principes de l'incertitude, alors vous savez,
je vais le lire rapidement -- et probablement l'éditer un peu,
parce que je n'ai plus beaucoup de temps -- quelques chroniques.
Et en fait, j'étais si, vous savez, c'était si amusant
parce que j'ai dit :"Bon, qu'est-ce que j'ai comme place?
Et ils ont dit,"Et bien, vous savez, c'est internet."
et j'ai dit : "qu'est-ce que j'ai comme place?"
Et ils ont dit, "c'est illimité, c'est illimité."
OK. Alors pour la première j'étais très timide, et je commençais.
"Comment puis-je vous dire tout ce qu'il y a dans mon coeur ?
Impossible de commencer. Assez. Non. Commence avec l'infortuné dodo ."
Et je parle du dodo, et comment le dodo s'est éteint,
et ensuite je parle de Spinoza.
"Comme le dernier dodo était en train de mourir, Spinoza cherchait une explication rationnelle
pour tout, appelée eudemonia.
Et alors il a rendu son dernier soupir avec ceux qu'il aimait près de lui,
et je sais qu'il a eu du bouillon de poule pour son dernier repas."
Je sais que c'est un fait avéré.
Et puis il est mort, et il n'y avait plus de Spinoza. Eteint.
Et puis, nous n'avons pas de Spinoza empaillé
mais nous avons un chien de Pavlov empaillé,
et je l'ai vu au musée de l'hygiène à St Petersburg en Russie.
Et le voilà, avec cette horrible boite électrique sur la croupe
dans ce fantastique palais décrépit.
"Et je pense que ça a dû être un jour très, très sombre
quand les bolcheviks sont arrivés.
Peut être qu'ils ont bien ri entre eux,
mais Staline était paranoïaque, encore plus que mon père."
(rires)
Vous n'avez même pas idée.
"Et il décida que ses gens les plus importants devaient être éteints."
Ce que j'ai inventé je crois, ce qui est une bonne chose.
Et donc, avec ce graphique de, vous savez, juste un petit graphique,
parce que le graphique n'aurait pas de fin avec tous les gens qu'il a tué.
Alors, tués par balle, assommés, vous savez, jetés.
"La famille de Nabokov a fuit la Russie. Comment est-ce que le jeune Nabokov
assis innocemment et élégamment sur une chaise rouge,
à feuilleter un livre et des papillons,
imagine un tel changement, une telle perte.
Et ensuite je veux vous dire que c'est une carte.
Donc, " La merveilleuse famille de ma mère a aussi fuit la Russie,
trop de pogroms.
Quittant leur cabane, les champs de mûres sauvages, les oies, la rivière Sluch,
ils sont allés en Palestine et puis en Amérique."
Et ma mère a dessiné cette carte des Etats Unis d'Amérique pour moi,
et c'est mon ADN ici, parce que la personne avec qui j'ai grandi
n'avait absolument aucun intérêt pour les faits.
En fait, les faits étaient bannis de chez nous.
Et donc, si vous vous voyez que le Texas, vous savez le Texas et la Californie
sont sous le Canada, et que la Caroline du Sud est au dessus de la Caroline du Nord,
c'est comme ça que j'ai grandi, OK ?
Alors c'est un miracle que je sois ici aujourd'hui.
Mais en fait, non, c'est en fait une chose merveilleuse.
Mais alors elle dit Tel Aviv et Lénine,
qui est la ville d'où ils viennent, et désolée, le reste est inconnu, merci.
Mais dans leur lexique, ça veut dire désolé le reste inconnu est
désolé le reste inconnu, allez au diable,
parce qu'elle s'en fichait.
(rires)
L'impossibilité de février,
est que février est un mois misérable à New York
et les images pour moi ramènent ces choses affreuses --
bon, pas si horribles.
J'ai reçu une boite dans le courrier et elle était emballée dans du papier journal
et il y avait la photo d'un homme sur le journal et il était mort.
Et je dis, "J'espère qu'il n'est pas vraiment mort,
qu'il apprécie juste de se rafraîchir en s'allongeant dans la neige,
mais la légende dit qu'il est mort."
Et en fait il l'était, je crois qu'il était mort vous savez,
peut être qu'il n'est pas mort.
"Et cette femme se penche, toute angoissée, pas pour l'homme
mais pour toutes les choses tristes, ça arrive souvent en février."
Il y a des consolations.
Cet homme est en colère parce que quelqu'un a jeté des oignions dans les escaliers,
et au fond -- vous savez je crois que les oignons sont un thème ici --
et il dit, "C'est impossible de ne pas mentir.
C'est février et ne pas mentir est impossible."
Et je passe vraiment beaucoup de temps à me demander,
quelle part de vérité nous disons ?
Qu'est ce que -- quelle histoire racontons-nous vraiment ?
Comment savons nous quand nous sommes nous même ?
Comment savons-nous que ces phrases qui sortent de nos bouches
sont de vraies histoires, vous savez, de vrais phrases ?
Ou est-ce que ce sont de fausses phrases que nous pensons devoir dire ?
Je vais parler de ça rapidement.
Une citation de Bertrand Russel,
"Tout le travail de tous les temps, toute la dévotion, toute l'inspiration,
toute la brillance de midi du génie humain
sont voués à l'extinction.
Alors maintenant mes amis, si c'est vrai,
et c'est vrai, à quoi ça sert ?"
Une question compliquée.
Et donc, vous savez, je parle à mes amis
et je vais à des spectacles où ils chantent des chansons russes --
Oh mon Dieu, vous savez quoi ?
Pourrions-nous -- non, nous n'avons pas le temps.
J'ai enregistré ma tante, j'ai enregistré ma tante en train de chanter en russe de --
Vous savez, pourrait-on écouter pour une seconde ?
Vous l'avez ?
(musique)
OK, j'ai enregistré -- ma tante nageait dans l'océan
tous les jours de l'année jusqu'à ce qu'elle ait 85 ans.
Donc c'est une chanson sur comment tout le monde est malheureux
parce que vous savez, nous venons de Russie.
(rires)
J'ai été voir Kitty Carlisle Hart, et elle a 96 ans,
et quand je lui amené un exemplaire de "Les éléments du style,"
elle a dit qu'elle y tiendrait beaucoup.
Et j'ai dit, oh, et elle parlait de Moss Hart, et j'ai dit,
tu sais, quand tu le recontrais, tu savais que c'était lui,
et elle a dit, je savais que c'était lui.
(rires)
Je suis celle qui aurait dû garder le livre mais c'était un moment vraiment merveilleux.
Et elle est sortie avec George Gershwin,vous savez, sortie.
Gershwin est mort à 38 ans.
Il est enterré au même cimetière que mon mari.
Je ne veux pas parler de ça maintenant.
Je veux parler -- le glaçage parfait sur le gâteau du cimetière
c'est le mausolée de la famille Barricini à côté.
Je pense que la famille Barricini aurait dû y ouvrir une boutique et vendre du chocolat.
(rires)
Et je voudrais la tenir pour eux.
Et j'ai été voir Louise Bourgeoise,
qui travaille encore, et j'ai regardé son évier,
qui est vraiment incroyable, et je suis partie.
Et ensuite j'ai photographié et peint un canapé dans la rue.
Et une femme qui vit dans notre rue, Lolita.
Et ensuite je vais prendre un thé.
Et ensuite ma tante Frances meurt, et avant de mourir
elle essayait de payer pour son baguel avec des paquets d'édulcorant.
(rires)
Et je me demande à quoi ça sert et puis je sais, je vois
que Hy Meyerowitz, le père de Rick Meyerow,
un vendeur de produits pour les pressings qui venait du Bronx,
a gagné le concours de sosie de Charlie Chaplin en 1931.
C'est Hy.
Et je regarde une belle coupe de fruits,
et je regarde une robe que j'ai faite pour une amie à moi.
Et elle dit, Ich habe genug, ce qui est un cantate de Bach,
ce qui je croyais voulait dire, j'en ai assez, je n'en peux plus,
laissez-moi, mais j'avais tort.
Ça veut dire, j'en ai assez -- et ça c'est vrai.
Je suis vivante, fin de la discussion. Merci.
(applaudissements)